こんにちははじめ雪道です
今日
従業カードの大会に行ってきます
卍あの基本悠遊カードの動画打ってサブチャンネルんでしか出さないんですけど今日は
堂々とはメインチャンネルで私肇社長が
遊戯王カードの代替に行ってきまーす
ってどんな大会かと言いますとその公式の島民の大会というのがありましてう気を作っ
ている会社が認めた
店舗お店で行われる店舗大会みたいな葉っぱって今回それに参加していきます
どれだけ頑張った子とか居るこの大会のために
昨日の夜くらいから少しずつショップに行って
デュエリストの友達たちと考え試行錯誤し秒力完成させた私のがいるデッキで今回は
大会でどこまで行けるのか皆さんにお見せしようと思いますもう負けたらそこで終了の
大会ですから弾人くるかもちょっとわからないしてもう結果どう
なるか分からないんですけども今日はこのサイコロ日曜日に
大君入ってくれると思い本当に結構ねいろいろ考えたんですよ今回
なんだか大会でたことがあるんですけど今回はれてね本気で結構考えたデッキなので
これで負けたら僕はそこまでの人間ってはだけど運もあるんで一概に勝てるとは言え
ないんですけども
を簡単にいます私のデッキは帰るか
てやがれてデッキですね中古どこが便利なのかなこの子が私の的な主人公
持ち替えちゃんですこの子を使って相手にどこまで嫌がらせをできるから僕のデッキの
戦い方の正味 trap card っていうね相手を様するカードをたくさん入れ
てるんでそこでどこまで相手に嫌がらせたできるかが今回の戦いに秘訣になっており
ます
あとはじゃんけんですじゃんけんで勝てば多分勝てます今のゆ行ですね色んなデッキが
輝けるんでいろんなで着替えるでその中で油膜と対策して勝たなきゃいけないという
わけで果たしてはず一つはどれほどいう行カードは強い7こんな皆様にお見せしようと
思いますこれはがんばってきた
[音楽]
こうつくを考えいろんな場面を想定しいろんなカードを入れて
言葉で行ってきた
何よはぁ
会社ん
大ちょっと山
まにゃの ann
hauhau
というわけでショップに行きました
上地店長さんの許可とって一応動画が撮れることになったのでちょっと大会でどこまで
いけるか今日な
やっていきたいとおもいます
父ジャイ子
ビストロ15分サイド15分3秒ぐらいじゃないの
健康で
none
taipei ニール
spl ed 皮膚科の医師激辛通常も三大巨匠も競った
それで得ないじゃん
[音楽]
voodoo
有望だったからそれからお願いします
ok
それ言ってくれません can you do
すぎるいいんです
[音楽]
パパ打撲
水瀬にで
行けます
ありましたねーポートおり捧げましています
一方いただきますんじゃ
ha
たーーーー影
wh
ペンが日本にある程度上げさーせん
[音楽]
ああああああ
dj 悪い
naruho い
そういうことで
てるアレですなぁ
wh
re
これはっけーん
wh
終わりましたございません
anoano 決勝の最終ラウンド4歳でご視聴者
ございますあまりの
[音楽]
voodoo
ですかああああ怖いのエキシ作ったんだよ
pou dou dou
[音楽]
優勝しました
続けた
[音楽]
me
uh
car
あっはぁ